[Music]
cheryl burke seemingly throwing shade at
ex matthew lawrence
i mean people evolve and
people sometimes unfortunately grow and
grow apart the dancing with the stars
pro shares a cryptic message on tick
tock six months after filing for divorce
from the boy meets world star
cheryl writes quote when he said he
would never talk to her again yet i
found text messages viagra and a
necklace hidden in a pair of his shoes
hello
matt and i have been through so much
yeah cheryl's eye roll says it all and
the caption goes there
quote the last time is absolutely right
goodbye forever
she adds hashtags quote x's suck and
quote hope it was worth it i didn't have
any sense of self or awareness this
comes weeks after cheryl revealed how
the split impacts her sobriety journey
i think people tend to think that my
life is perfect and you know through
this divorce that i've i'm still going
through there's a lot of ups and downs
but i have to put myself first i have to
put my sobriety first cheryl and matt's
romance began in 2007 before breaking it
off the following year my married
friends are just like they're testing it
out you know they're like how does it
feel because i don't think a lot of my
friends thought i was ever going to get
married fast forward nearly a decade
later they reunited how does it feel to
be back together and just be happy it's
great it's really great because you are
happy what was it that made you guys
know you know we want to do this again
for me it was like a text message last
december
saying hey
wanna have dinner merry christmas and
then that was it the two married in 2019
but less than three years later cheryl
filed for divorce on valentine's day
according to an insider at the time
their split was quote a long time coming
and in legal documents obtained by e.t
she cited irreconcilable differences
i think it's important that you know i
move on as cheryl said back in may
there's no regrets about how the
marriage ended i don't wish i
i did anything differently i think you
know we did try we were in couples
therapy um and at the end of the day i
think that communication is key and it's
also important to be able to be heard as
for her love life post-divorce cheryl's
not opposed to walking down the aisle
again
are there things you missed about being
married would you see yourself getting
married again totally yes i would and i
do i mean i miss that just the
compatibility that just being with
another person another human being you
know it's now just me and my frenchie
which i can't complain about thank god
for her there's moments for sure of
sadness and
reflection and
just wanting to be able to share your
life with somebody and i'm not
definitely not
saying i'll never get married again for
sure
[Music]